everyone says that they want to innovate
but then myself and my teams would go
into companies and the very people that
hired us to come in and help them
innovate were the very people that were
holding us back from doing it when we
got there and I thought well you know
why and it was this whole idea of risk
fear power control risk aversion and I
started to ask everybody that I met a
very simple question to get at the
problem of why people were not able to
innovate the way that they should
here was the question I asked them what
do you spend your day doing and you know
what the answer was I wasn't surprised
by the uniqueness of the answer I was
surprised by the absolute consistency of
it so if I talk to let's say a hundred
thousand people a year across all
different countries companies industries
levels within the organization and I
asked them what did they spend their day
doing do you know what they say meetings
and emails now I believe that people get
up every day to do meaningful things I
don't have a single friend that wakes up
looks at their inbox and feels extra
popular because they have more people
that have contacted them people don't
want to spend their day doing that they
want to work on work that matters so I
think that getting to work that is
simpler and eliminating those
complexities or mundane tasks are not
just going to make people more
productive at work but they're gonna be
more satisfied they're gonna have a
sense of purpose and our businesses the
results that we have there are going to
be dramatically better because of it
so what I did is I tried to come up with
a very succinct definition for
simplicity and I realize it's less of a
definition and more around guidelines
and I think there's four components to
simplicity the first is being as minimal
as possible second is understandable as
possible
the third is repeatable as possible and
the final is accessible as possible now
most people just think of the first part
minimal right making it less than and I
think that that's true but there's so
much more than just that being able to
minimize something get rid of parts
that's a good first step with simplicity
the second piece is understandable and
that really gets to UM clarity we use so
much jargon so many catchphrases
so many more words than we need to
making it as understandable as possible
so we can get time back is key the next
thing is repeatable and repeatable is
important so we stopped making
everything so custom so one-off and it
also lets us leverage best practices
right you want teachers to make things
repeatable in a classroom so we benefit
from best practices you want pilots no
matter what cockpit they go into to have
the same experience that they can fly
the plane and then the last part is
accessible and that's really important
because that's about transparency when
you look at companies like Progressive
Insurance that made it transparent how
they do their pricing versus competitors
that's a real benefit when you look at
Google when they allowed everyone to use
their code so others could innovate
along with them to make their products
better that's the benefit of making
something accessible and simple so
there's more than just making something
minimal if you do those four components
minimal understandable repeatable and
accessible that's a great framework for
you to approach everything that you do
within your work